what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with X-Men red and fall of X is
coming to a close now a lot of you guys
expressed a lot of confusion about what
was happening in relation to X-Men red
down in the comments section of the last
video so because this is the final issue
we can kind of recap things so one of
the things to know is there are three
forces at play here right there is Storm
then there's Genesis and then there's
Annihilation and Annihilation isn't
somebody that we've really talked about
too much outside of the early
appearances that Marvel gave us what we
know from the main X-Men comic in issues
134 and 15 is that somewhere along the
line in the very early days of Earth
annihilation emerged as a being really
an elder god of just incredible power we
don't know her origin we have no idea
where she came from we assume that it
was in like the early days of the Elder
gods and cathon and Demi urge and all
that kind of stuff and she fled to that
Dimension but we don't know for certain
right just kind of left to our own
devices to make sense of it the
important thing here is that
Annihilation rules over a land called
Amoth which is basically like a really
dark world that's out there in some
other dimension but what she does is she
controls basically an army of demons
what it happened here is that ammen
somehow managed to get her hands on the
Twilight sword of serer again we don't
know how but with using the sword she
literally cut a hole through the fabric
of space and time which allowed her to
into the Earthly plane from the
dimension of Amoth and in doing so
unleash this horde of demonic beings on
Earth with the intention of conquering
it now of course again this is thousands
upon thousands of years ago and while
you did have apocalypse as one of the
oldest mutants in existence along with
his wife Genesis and their quote unquote
children not really biological but like
the four horsemen of apocalypse
essentially you also had a whole host of
mutants that had come into existence
somewhere along the line and it all kind
of been gathered together by apocalypse
himself but when this Invasion took
place one of these mutants named the
white sword along with his 100 Champions
invaded into the realm of amonth and
then basically held these demons off as
long as they possibly could now the
reason white sword was able to do this
and we'll talk more about that as we get
through this video is that he was able
to basically heal himself and his
soldiers continually but for thousands
of years every morning white swword
would resurrect his Soldier and even
himself if he needed to and then go back
out to fight again but again they
weren't able to hold the demons off
forever what did happened during this
time is Annihilation entered into the
Earthly plane and then actually had a
meeting with Genesis herself as a way to
basically cease the conflict right to
end the invasion But ultimately none of
it worked out right it simply didn't
happen we didn't know the reason why
that whole meeting just kind of went
sour we ended up learning that Genesis
very much beli believed in the
philosophy that Only the Strong deserve
to survive and so the idea of people
waging an endless war as a way of
improving themselves was something she
very much celebrated and that actually
is what caused the ending of the meeting
she didn't want the fighting to stop and
So eventually Genesis and her forces
enter into the realm of amonth to join
the white sword and his 100 forces and
then the breach is sealed apocalypse
stays on Earth along with all those
mutants that were with him and that was
basically it and apocalypse ever since
then had basically been going through
and engaging in his schemes of testing
mutants and all that kind of stuff as a
way to ensure that when the portal was
reopened Earth's mutant population could
enter in he could rejoin his wife they
could destroy Annihilation and the day
would be saved such as it was with the
mutants existing on the island of okara
when the breach was sealed okara was cut
in half the Earthly side was kcoa the
other side that was stuck in the
dimension of amonth became oraco and so
the results of this is that you
basically had Genesis and her forces
constantly fighting for thousands upon
thousands of years against the forces of
annihilation now the other part of this
is ISA who's not overly important to
this part of the story she's basically
done but the power of Isa is that she
will always win no matter what her power
compels her to join whatever side will
inevitably win the other reason why the
whole parlay the meeting failed was
because Isa Allied herself with
Annihilation which was a signal to the
forces of Genesis and everybody that
there was no conceivable way to win but
maintaining her belief system she
continued fighting anyway what ended up
happening is there came a point when
Genesis challenged Annihilation and then
ultimately defeated Annihilation and the
result of this is that there was no real
leader out there for all the demons that
existed and that's when everybody within
amonth came to the realization it's only
a matter of time before these demons who
were leaderless end up overrunning the
entirety of Genesis and the white swords
forces find some way into Earth and then
conquer it and so what Genesis had done
is she had dawned the Helm of
annihilation and when this happened the
spirit of annihilation took over Genesis
and that's why we're where we are right
now because Genesis is basically being
controlled by Annihilation herself and
the idea of Genesis was to consolidate
all the forces within amonth under her
control the demons the white sword and
his Champions her Army the whole nine
yards and launch an invasion of Earth
now as for oraco the actual oraco Mars
itself this was just Mars in Marvel
Comics for years like a red planet which
is just over there and that was it but
when you got to the 10 of Swords event
which you'll find in the playlist
leading up to fall of X the whole ending
of that was really more just kind of an
agreement that was struck between the
mutants on Earth so like the X-Men
basically and those mutants that lived
in ameth if they wanted to leave and
come to the main Marvel Universe they
could but because of the fact that
mutants from amons only believed and
knew conflict they couldn't coexist with
mutants on earth right because by all
standards of measurement when you take
the life that Genesis and her forces
lived versus the life that the X-Men on
Earth lived the X-Men were basically
just kicking back with their feet
propped up with a cocon of smile that's
really all it was right their life was
very very cushy because they weren't
fighting for survival every single day
of their existence metaphorically yes
physically no and so because of that
those mutants that left amonth and then
came to the Earthly plane they took up
residence on Mars and then they renamed
Mars to acko and then formed their own
governing body what is it like the great
Ring I think is what it was called which
consists of some of the most powerful
mutants in existence right all of them
are Omega Level mutants all that came to
a head during Judgment
Day right like it's a whole bunch of
stuff that happened but like during the
events of of Judgment Day in effect the
eternals went to war against the X-Men
and that one of these really old
eternals by the name of uranos wiped out
pretty much all the mutants that resided
on Mars oraco and so what it did is that
when Genesis under the control of
annihilation left amonth and made her
move to basically attack the main Marvel
Universe oraco was the first place she
went to because it was at the weakest
point there was really no one there
protecting it it was like the equivalent
of somebody tried to attack Earth and
most all of Earth superheroes were
destroyed before that person launched
their attack it would be like if Thanos
showed up on Earth and wiped out most of
the superheroes and then left and then
Galactus was like I'm going to consume
earth right like who's going to be there
to stop it so that's kind of how things
were going on at this particular point
in time with regards to Mars and all
that that's how we get here storm was
originally a kind of in between for
oraco and like the X-Men on Earth and
became part of the governing body just
from trial by conflict and just being
amazing right is really all it was but
that's why this conflict is happening
the way that it is something to
understand here as we get into this
right after ending all this history if
storm loses this war against Genesis
it's the most important thing if storm
loses this war against Genesis everybody
on Earth will fall all the mutants on
Earth will fall because the forces of
Genesis and Genesis herself with the
backing of annihilation power dwarfs the
ability of most everybody out there in
the Marvel Universe with conventional
powers Thor well the century is dead
Hulk all those guys they will fall
against the forces of amonth and
Annihilation all these demons and
mutants and the whole nine yards that's
why this war is being waged on oraco so
again as always you'll find a link to
the playlist at the end of this but
getting into the story itself what we
did as we ended the last video is we had
storm who showed up literally
manifesting a gigantic Island a gigantic
land mass which she was using to
basically engage in a conflict against
Genesis who does the exact same thing
right she kind of manifests her own
gigantic Island now the reality here is
this is symbolic more than anything else
right oraco versus kcoa kindness versus
evil like however you want to put it
right whatever you want to put it that's
more symbolic but the fight between
storm and Genesis is anything but it is
a knockdown drag out fight but storm
figures out very very fast that Genesis
is basically dabbling in three sources
of power the first is her in ability
which is to manipulate plant life kind
of cool right nothing really special
going on there but the other two things
are the objects she has in her
possession the first is the white sword
that literally belonged to White sword
himself with this sword she can heal
from virtually any injury and any attack
and assuming that it gives her powers
comparable to White sword himself she
can resurrect herself from the dead and
so as long as she has this sword in her
possession there's no real means of
defeating her the other thing is the
staff she has and that's what's
channeling the power of annihilation and
that's what's actually influencing
Genesis herself and so in this fight
between the two the first thing storm
does is she basically whisks the sword
away from Genesis but she does it in
like a really really coel and
manipulative fashion the reason why is
because she just starts hammering down
lightning onto Genesis herself but
getting into the main fight between
storm and Genesis it's phenomenal the
way this unfolds right so like the first
thing Genesis does is she literally just
uses her power to basically sprout a
whole bunch of vines which immediately
seiz themselves around storm and with
anybody else would probably start
choking them to death but storm with her
power uses the weather to freeze the
vines and then once they're frozen
breaks free of them which is just dope
it's so cool to see storm use her powers
in that way it's one of the things that
I love about this is it shows us how
storm uses her abilities in ways that we
don't normally get to see it's small but
it's genius at the same time now what
storm ends up doing is she initially
launches a lightning attack to destroy
the staff of Genesis but one of the
things that we're told here is that to
hear the whisper of annihilation is to
have to obey Annihilation now this is
where things get a little finicky here
because what we had known is that when
it came to Annihilation control over the
demons from the realm of Amoth it was
just her power to be able to control
them but there wasn't really anything to
seemingly indicate that unless a person
is in possession of the mass or the
staff of annihilation kind of both
operating as the same thing here that
they could be controlled by Annihilation
what this seems to indicate here is that
Annihilation can influence those around
her it's not as intense as it would be
if storm was in possession of the staff
but it is enough that when storm
launches her attack with lightning
Annihilation simply says Miss and storm
misses the staff but it's actually kind
of a boon here and the reason why is
because when she misses it does hit the
sword but the sword kind of acts like a
lightning rod right it's literally made
of metal and so it's not enough to like
destroy Genesis but it is enough to kind
of knock her off her guard and then
realizing the capabilities of the sword
storm whisks it away using her wind or
her ability to control the wind now the
thing about the sword is that it's not
that dissimilar from the Infinity Stones
in terms of how it works not in the
ability to like manipulate all of
reality in some form or fashion but as
we know from like the Illuminati Stories
the Infinity Stones want to be together
right they're always trying to find a
way back to each other the sword itself
functions in the exact same way white
sword is the true owner of the sword and
so when the sword is seemingly whisked
away he can feel it being removed from
Genesis just like Thor and his hammer he
sticks his hand in the air recalls The
Sword and his powers are right back to
him again right he's just as capable as
he ever was now what this does is it
switches over to a fight between white
sword and John iron fire it's not the
most significant part of this story but
it is kind of cool because it does allow
us to focus on why I would argue white
sword is probably one of the most
powerful mutants to ever exist in Marvel
Comics the idea behind white sword and
why he's so significant is with the
sword that he has and with his inherent
mutant power he can heal from anything
and not only can he heal he can actually
resurrect himself from the dead which is
one of the coolest things right that's
one of the reasons why white swword and
his 100 Champions were able to wage that
endless war against Annihilation and her
forces and Amoth because sure his
soldiers would fall they would die but
every morning he would resurrect them
from the dead and the battle would
continue once more so the fact that this
guy can never truly die and can even
bring himself back makes him a force
that's virtually Unstoppable the only
caveat to this would be like some
reality War Bird or something crazy like
that but the fight between himself and
John iron side is cool because of the
fact that John and wh sword sword were a
thing at one point right a rift was
formed between the two of them just
based on ideologies white sword followed
Genesis Ironside followed storm and just
based on those ideologies things just
simply didn't work out but even now
there is a kind of fight not really to
the death but a very intense battle
taking place between the two of them but
what's cool here is that Jon's able to
get the upper hand on white swword just
long enough to take his sword from him
and cleave him in half but that's when
white sword says like I will heal from
this right like you have to know there's
no way for me to die and the only way
that I will fall is with the defeat of
Genesis right if she falls her cause is
no longer my own but as long as she
leads my forces and the forces of
annihilation along with her own I will
follow her to whatever end that may be
now the next thing we end up doing is
actually switching over to the main
fight between the forces of storm and
the forces of Genesis because remember
they brought their own armies with them
and for the most part it's a pretty
knockdown drag out fight this is a war a
fight among mostly Omega Level mutants
not all but most what's kind of funny
about this is that on this battlefield
here the most powerful among them is
also the most useless among them and
that is Ora Sara oras sarata is the one
with just like the giant eyeball the
reason why I say this is that as part of
the Inner Circle right the great Ring of
oraco its governing body Ora Sara has
the ability to wipe people from
existence literally she could just like
travel through this entire Battlefield
and just start zapping people and it'll
be like they never existed the kicker
about all this is that can only happen
if you recognize the validity of the
legal system she represents so if you
see no validity in it or you choose not
to believe in it her powers are useless
against you so it's a massive caveat
against an otherwise astronomically
powerful character and so that's why
despite all her B that of abilities and
the ability to simply just end these
conflicts in the blink of an eye none of
it matters and there's nothing she can
do to end this battle but that's why
she's kind of going through saying all
of you have to stop right I am the law
the law endures the law survives all
like all that kind of stuff but oros
sarata's lack of power ultimately proves
to be your downfall and the reason why
is because fisher king steps in now
here's the cool thing about fisher king
it's kind of cool but it sucks at the
same time and the reason why is because
fisher king was a guy that never had any
abilities whatsoever technically the
people of oraco they refer to their
powers as weapons but what he says is
that he had no weapon once and that
defined him and of course the reason why
fisher king is so significant is because
of the fact that in a Land of people
most all of whom have Omega Level powers
that are fighting every day for their
lives he was a guy with no powers that
was still able to maintain his own
Survival so is he as powerful as
everybody here no he has no abilities
but he did earn all their respect but
the thing about this is that at one
point he was bonded with Zelo now Zelo
is from oraco and it's actually not a
singular organism but more like a giant
collection of worms that basically have
the ability to like wipe out human bone
right or at least to consume any and all
substances that they come into contact
with what ends up happening here is that
when fiser King makes his move that
Zillo actually bonds itself directly to
oras serata and in doing so consumes
orera it actually eats orera destroys
orera so like it's just kind of
completely and totally dissolved it'll
become important here in a little bit
but at that point we transition back to
storm and this is the cool fight between
storm and Genesis because what goes on
here is Storm asked the question do you
see what your War has done Genesis do
you see the only way that it can win
with continents torn from the Bedrock
whole Seas boiled or Frozen with the end
of this world that the argument storms
making here is yes you believe in
survival of the fittest yes you believe
that Only the Strong deserve to survive
but what you do not account for is what
we as X-Men account for which is
collateral damage of what use is being
the victor of some Great War if there is
no land for you to rule anymore or to be
in control of anymore right like
congratulations you are queen of a world
that doesn't exist right but the
response of Genesis is you say that you
don't do it you claim to be Omega Level
but can you burn both these islands
murder the world that you cre created do
you truly have no limmit no you're not
strong enough but I am the true Avatar
of life and life is an endless war right
so it's just an argument or really kind
of a fight of philosophies right like
Thomas Hall life is short brutish and
cruel act accordingly right storm who's
very much not like that and is far more
You could argue empathetic in terms of
her belief system but it's one of these
things where even with Genesis saying
that it's understanding the nature of
what it means to be Omega Level they
both have the same definition for the
most part right having powers with no
defined limit right that's why storm is
Omega Level because sure she can control
the storms of Worlds but what would
happen if storm could control Cosmic
storms right storm just traveling from
solar system to solar system with a
power of a cosmic storm behind her she
would be like a new galatis just laying
waste to entire sections of the universe
and one Fell Swoop but with Genesis it's
much the same way the difference is that
being Omega Level is not just a
definition of your power it's a
definition of your will how far are you
willing to go to ensure that your goal
is achieved and in the case of Genesis
she'll do whatever she has to do she'll
kill whoever she has to kill it doesn't
matter right everybody will fall so it
is a cool moment here right a massive
difference of philosophies and she even
says everything that lives fights to
survive each breath is a battle simply
to function your body makes slaves of
billions of microscopic fungi now at my
command they turn against you when the
weak do not serve the strong the body
dies that's what became of okara in the
end it was the greatest beauty of that
ancient world but it lost and we lost
the only Victory is in survival the only
survival lies in strength Annihilation
called the weak to make way for the
strong now it serves me and the coal Has
Come Again the humans on Earth are
winnowing we mutants not knowing that
they are thus dooming themselves to my
rule and the thing about this is that as
storm is literally just kind of laying
there right bleeding from the mouth all
hope looks like it's effectively lost
right storm is about to lose she seizes
control of the staff of annihilation and
when that happens Annihilation speaks
directly to her and this is one of the
coolest points of the story right it
says you are dying your body is turning
against you your organs fail one by one
death who you have danced with so many
times ready to take you in his arms but
I can offer you a way out a reprieve and
what Annihilation says is Genesis was my
way into this world the need in her the
confirmation of her world view was a
beacon calling me from Amoth and I was
called to that Dark World from the Lands
Beyond but Genesis has outgrown her use
it took far too long the first time to
cajo her from her endless prison to
further Conquest given the choice she
will maintain and maintain a Siege
maintain her power maintain a status quo
that serves her and I I would grow and
so literally she says to satisfy that
desire I must at least make the offer
the whole reason for this is because
annihilation in one looking at what
Storm's capable of in terms of her power
and two look looking at what storm could
achieve and how angry she is how
wrathful she can be she's almost kind of
like this perfect host for annihilation
why Annihilation says your needs are
more noble you are not motivated as much
by personal Glory but I do not concern
myself with motivations only with
results and so it's one of these cool
things because storm ultimately doesn't
care in listening to the words of
annihilation and in paying attention to
everything that happened so far she
realized that Annihilation whispering in
her ear to miss is why she missed the
first time but Annihilation isn't saying
that now Annihilation is trying to turn
storm to her side but Storm's will is
far too strong and so in this moment
with the staff in her possession she
calls down the lightning and obliterates
it right like we're literally told
Genesis screamed not from the pain but
from the loss the empty space in her
soul where a sweet whisper had lived her
ancient foe her oldest friend Genesis
was Hardy and could survive the
lightning but the staff in the end was
only wood and fragile gold and could not
and so in effect storm in destroying the
staff destroys the essence of
annihilation it's gone storm literally
just killed a God and while you do get a
couple people in the aftermath of this
in realizing that Genesis has
effectively been defeated that what
happens is they stand up and they refuse
to accept it they refuse to bend the
knee to storm and accept storm as their
new ruler but or Sada really more like
Zilo serata if you want to call her that
kind of arrives on the scene and with
the power at their disposal and storm
being the rightful ruler Zelo in control
of orera recognizes storm as the
legitimate winner because all laws in
arao are determined in trial by combat
storm defeated Genesis storm is now the
ruler that is the law of the land
therefore those individuals who believe
in aqi law but refuse to believe that
storm is the winner are now subject to
the power of oros serata and she just
starts annihilating them from existence
and even says like is there anybody else
out there who would defy me for a broken
mask and every single one of them bends
the knee they accept the fact that storm
is a legitimate winner here and that
storm is now their ruler but here's the
cool thing about all this right here's
what's going to blow your mind about all
this this does effectively end X-Men red
Genesis herself ends up taking off to a
space station that's orbiting Mars right
out there by Phobos whatever and like
she may or may not return who really
cares the X-Men red comic is getting
relaunched and gets what's happening
with issue number one if you guys recall
my friends in Judgment day if you guys
have noticed especially those of you
guys who are new who haven't been
following everything there is is someone
from the X-Men universe who has been
missing we have not seen him for quite
some time and if you read Judgment Day
you know why because Magneto is dead but
in the relaunch of X-Men red Marvel's
bringing him back they're resurrecting
Magneto and I am so hyped about this oh
my God I love Magneto honestly I wish
he'd been here cuz Magneto would have
ended this conflict like that right he
would have just been like boom
everybody's done all right cool let's
all go out for fish and chips it would
have been amazing but with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end if you need to get caught up on
fall of X which you should because we're
about a two or three weeks from it
ending make sure you click this link to
the playlist and I will catch you all
later peace